money does offer this really cool thing
which is uh I won't experience in my
life like I want to know what it's like
to completely check out from
uh to use the manosphere term if you
will the the the the the Matrix like I
want to know what it's like to do
everything in my life because I want to
do it not because I have to and
um you know maybe I'm not sorry from the
Matrix is what you're talking exactly
yeah so it's like the red pill Andrew uh
listen I'm doing it no but I believe
it's like so rare because I don't think
it's like very natural to do that as a
human so I'm curious like and I don't
know how much money you got I think I
know you got some money I'm borrowing
money from you
but like but like when you get to the
point where you don't have to work right
yeah
a weird thing happens you have to find
something that you want it what I've
always done is like I've gone I'm going
to do what I love and find a way to make
money at it because I don't want to do
something I don't love because that's
going to drive me crazy but if I love
something then I can put everything in
it and I can just give it my all and I
just love every day like I love going to
the studio when I wear I love calling I
love these yeah but what happens when
you don't have to that's what I'm
curious and like do you remember that
moment
like was it depressing a little bit like
you almost stop being part of human
evolution
right like up until people weren't
supposed to have hundreds of millions of
dollars yeah right and then you get it
that's how your brain is designed do you
have to trick your brain into thinking
you're still surviving it's it's a very
good question by the way this whole Utah
thing coming out are you talking about
Pete Davidson with uh you know wanting
to be a Jew are you thinking about
joining the Church of Mormon or LDS is
that kind of where you're going with
this is that with the life change
Joseph Smith is that the Direction no
not it's so funny because I went there
for I went there for uh it's a great
place by the way I went there for
Thanksgiving I didn't know it's on
Navajo land oh wow so I'm spending
Thanksgiving on [ __ ] Native Americans
no alcohol dry county I'm not worried
about dry I'm just getting the saddest
Happy Thanksgiving from these
[ __ ] like it is the most tragic
[ __ ] day like it was bro it was
brutal and it's a little chilly in the
morning so like when you're eating
outside they're like can we offer you a
blanket or something I'm like I am
falling for that one but but no I am
really curious what happens in life when
you can unplug so when you can when it's
a choice a choice right so this is
everything from at least for me I like
things to be a clear systems steps uh
you know where the more clarity I have
the better I do the more distracted I am
the worst I do so the key for me is
Clarity and anticipation is one of the
biggest uh uh uh advantages you can have
if you anticipate like what you just did
right on the podcast you may not even be
aware of it you anticipate it like
what's gonna have my daughter from
living in Miami and she's dating she's
sucking she's wrong you're thinking
you're anticipating what happens I mean
I was thinking about having a daughter
at 23 years old am I ready to have a
daughter do I want to have that fear I
had that fear at 23 years old you're
anticipating your question you're asking
right now is anticipating I broke it
down in four 20-year runs first 20 year
don't make a big stupid mistake okay
second 20 year go make your money okay
third twenty year pursue whatever you
want creative by choice last 20 year
contribution where you want to go
politics you want to go do you know you
know whatever you want to do that's the
last one one if you want to go to
anything without okay so that breakdown
is okay I gotta make my money first a
guy calls me from Hollywood who says hey
man I watch a podcast closely and but I
can't talk like you think I should open
up a podcast and really tell people how
I feel that's how much money you get in
the bank he says uh about eight hundred
thousand dollars so what do you got in
every asset stocks everything that's
about 1.4 million I said how old are you
35 years old 38 years old I said okay
you don't have a few money yet because
if you do that in Hollywood you're done
you're done if you're Clint Eastwood say
whatever the hell you want to say you
got 500 million dollars on the bank
you're good to go right so that's it's
different for you because you're a
comedian you get paid to talk [ __ ] so
you're a little bit more free to to say
that but
first time I had 10 grand in the bank I
was 21 I had got out of the army
it was freaking awesome first time I had
100 Grand I was like that's pretty tight
the first time I had a million in a bank
it was cool it was like this is legit a
million but 10 grand believe it or not
felt more special
first time 10 million it was like oh 10
million you actually felt free yeah
but when it hit a couple hundred it's a
different story
you kind of sitting here like yeah yeah
tell me about that yeah because I I
imagine and I don't know how big your
dream but like there's the number that
is [ __ ] you money for you yeah and that
number keeps growing but I'm not there
yet though yeah well where is it yeah
where is it well well I I don't I don't
think okay so because
um
love the game let's talk about the Love
of the Game yeah does Joe need to do
more podcasts because he needs money
does Joe need to do like you know how
you watch the UFC what's the best
reaction Joe has with Cormier oh he does
I mean everybody wants to see that right
it's like it's like how LeBron does
whatever he does in a sense he's like do
you just want to see Joe do this right
sick everybody reacts to it you know
there is something very special about a
guy who loves the game he's playing yep
there it's such a freaking beautiful
thing to see you sit there you say dude
I just know you will love your freaking
game yep and I want to watch you do it I
watch you do it I S I feel the love of
the game so for me I draw from that I'm
attracted to that right
and if I see somebody that's doing it
for them I like NBA there's some guys
like I wrote about a guy named Andrew
Bynum wanted to remember I didn't love
the game it was just seven one 260
pounds dude give this guy 100 million
bucks it's hard to find a 71260 guy
right but you see a Steph Curry play the
guy freaking loves the game he's having
fun dude it's Steph Curry may be
to me the most exciting guy to want to
walk because he loves the damn game so
when it becomes about the Love of the
Game it's no longer money you're
pursuing something else so unfortunately
if you're solving money 100 you're
eventually going to slow down if you're
pursuing a true vision cause purpose
Love of the Game it's tough to slow down
every night I come home my kids want to
play Domino we love the game of dominoes
like the Love of the Game for us so
that's how I would explain it to you
also another reason why I don't want to
grow up in Miami Domino's
[Laughter]
in New York though yeah right you're
right no but the thing about love of the
game which is interesting is
you don't know that it's pure until you
make enough money to not play very good
point very good point so it's like Steph
already had enough contracts he don't
got to play basketball yeah so the Love
of the Game for you I'm assuming is
multi-faceted building businesses yeah
but you're into this game as well yeah
and then maybe aspirations of uh
politics
maybe we find somebody like you and put
you in the white house maybe we do
certain things like that first of all
that's big money talk right there yeah
that's big money talk when when when I'm
a puppet you know what I mean yeah
that's that's how rich people talk about
people
broke it will put you in so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks right if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red or
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people were in the office they had
to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future looks
spread toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]